All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar
everyone. Before we introduce our
invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk. But if you
have question you can unmute and ask questions,
or use chatroom to post your questions so that
we can address them in q&a session. Second,
today's GDPR seminar is open to external audience
so no close by discussion is allowed. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. That's about it. Now, let me
briefly introduce our speaker today,
it is an honor to host the Dimitris
who is a jack Byrne or the professor
in mathematics at Dartmouth College.
He received a bachelor's and master's degree in
natural sciences from the University of Cambridge
in 2001, and PhD degree in physics from the
University of Chicago in 2009. Following a
postdoctoral appointment at the Courant Institute
of mathematical science in New York University
from 2009 to 2012, he was an Assistant Professor
and Associate Professor of of mathematics at
current until 2021, when he joined the Department
of Mathematics at dark mouth. His current research
focus is at the interface between operator
theoretic techniques for dynamical systems
and machine learning. And his recent work includes
the development of techniques for coherent pattern
pattern extractions, statistical forecasting
and Data Assimilation based on the data driven
approximation. So Koopman operators of dynamical
systems, he has worked on the applications of
these tools to atmosphere, ocean science,
fluid dynamics and molecular dynamics today
that Demetrius is going to talk
about the quantum information
and data science for modeling classical dynamics.
Please expect a wonderful talk and the stage
is yours now. Demetrius Thank you, Yong.
Yong, Soo, Ilan for inviting me thank everyone for
coming in person or remotely. So we'll be talking
about techniques for quantum information science
and Koopman operator theory for for modeling,
classical dynamical systems. This is
important work done in collaboration
with several people that I will acknowledge
as we go through through the talk. So, so,
this will allow Okay, so, to begin, I usually
like to show the snippet from classical paper
of Fineman, which in some ways ushered in the era
of quantum computing, where the idea that he puts
forward is that if nature is fundamentally quantum
mechanical, we should be using quantum systems
to simulate to simulate nature, in other words,
quantum systems should be used to simulate other
quantum systems
forming some notion of universal
quantum computation. So,
another problem I would like to talk about
today is kind of in the converse direction,
namely, we would like to use quantum
systems to simulate classical systems.
And the idea being that we want to harness
the power that quantum systems cover that
are not present in terms of information
processing, that are not that do not have
classical analogues to obtain some type of
computational advantage. So, this is a problem
that has also received a lot of attention
in in recent years. This is just a partial
list of of references, where
people have looked at different kinds of classical
systems and designed quantum algorithms or
thought about ways of incorporating quantum
mechanical descriptions to simulate them. So,
one of the challenges here is that there
is a little bit of a disparity between
the fact that you know, classical dynamical
systems are usually formulated in terms of
nonlinear systems of differential equations,
either ordinary differential equations or or
partial differential equations. Whereas quantum
systems, if you exclude at least measurement,
they evolve with unitary linear
linear operation. So there is no
immediate challenge about how to
it encodes a nonlinear dynamics in
terms of unitary or linear evolution.
And there are also other complexities involved
having to do with how you prepare the state of
the quantum computer to encode, given initial
conditions of the classical system. And also,
at the end of the computation, how
to make how to appropriately measure
the quantum state to extract the, you
know, the information that you want to
predict the quantity of interest to
the four seconds in the simulation.
So, these are all challenging and
interesting questions. And I will be
talking about work we've been doing
with collaborators in you know, hoping
to address at least part of them.
Okay, so, I should say also, that I'm happy to
be interrupted at any time during the talk with
questions, even if I don't get through the entire
material. So, we will be using our methodology
relies heavily on the operator theoretic
approaches to dynamic analysis systems, which
have been developed in work of core Neumann
Koopman, and others dating back to the 19 1930s.
And in this in this framework, one focuses
on the induced action have put generally
nonlinear dynamics on spaces of observables.
So, meaning functions of the state these are
quantities that one can measure like a
temperature or velocity and fluid flow.
And the idea here is that these spaces you
know, spaces have functions if the codomain So,
the output space is a linear space,
like a vector space, oftentimes,
this will be the real or, or complex numbers,
these spaces are actually linear, the meaning
we can add together functions, we can scale
or multiply functions, even if the underlying
state space of the classical system is does
not have linear structure. And, remarkably,
if we have a generally nonlinear flow, I'm
denoting with here by 50 on classical state space,
and by that I mean that there is a this
family of mappings parameterize by time,
such that they take in initial conditions
on the state space X and output the state
that the system has reached after dynamical
evolution for a time t. And this is gentleman
Yes. Excuse me. I'm sorry, I'm Henry,
I could so before you go further,
can you maybe like give a few like example of like
an a physical system what is x? What is funky?
Thanks for the question. So, maybe to cover as a
mental model a concrete example, suppose that x is
you know, three dimensional space or some
Euclidean space Rn and we have on x we have
specified a system of an ordinary differential
equations, think of for instance, the Lorenz 63
system that has the chaotic butterfly
attractor or think of the simple harmonic
oscillator if you know X was our to where
you have, you know, position and momentum
represented in that space. So you write down a
system of equations, you know, dx by dt equals
V of x, where V is some vector field, and you
solve the initial value problem that comes out
of that. And the solution defines this,
this dynamical, this dynamical flow fee,
this is the map that basically is the solution
map for a system of differential equations.
And, you know, these can also be generalized to
systems of partial differential equations where
now x instead of being a finite dimensional space
like Rn, it's actually itself a function space if
you if you're dealing with fluid mechanical
models, so x would be a space of functions on
some domain where you know, the fluid flow takes
place. Does that help clarify? Yeah, thanks.
Thanks. Yep. And again, please interrupt me if
anything is not clear. So, so now, given that we
have such a flow, we can define linear operators
associated with that flow that they act by
composition. So, a natural search operator,
which noun on the Koopman operator takes
observable. So functions in this space are
suitably chosen and composes them from the
right with with a dynamical flow. So this
effectively defines a transformation that
takes functions and produces new functions, you
can think of the function f composed with fi t
as some type of time evolved version of
of f, where instead of evaluating f at
any given classical state we're evaluating
it at. Since we're composing with this map,
we're evaluating at the state that the system
has reached after evolution by time t. And you
can check that this transformation is actually
linear, that the way we define this map from
functions to functions is actually a linear
map is now known as the Koopman operator.
Related operator that is also quite useful is the
transfer operator also known
as parent Frobenius operator.
And this is actually like an ad joint,
you can think of it as an ad joint
of the Koopman operator, which
is defined on the dual on a dual
space to F. I don't want to go into
the technical details here, but
we're thinking that for instance,
if f was a space of convenience functions on
x, then the dual space would be some space of
of measures like Like for instance
probability probability measures,
and the baronne Frobenius operator
describes the action of a dynamical
system on spaces of of measures. And this is
useful in studying probabilistic aspects of
classical dynamics namely, how probability
distributions evolve under general nonlinear
dynamics, because applications in forecasting
uncertainty quantification and so on,
but the main message here is that these this
perspective allows one basically to study
general nonlinear dynamics by leveraging
tools from the theory of linear operators.
This is this is something that has received
this approach has received a
fair amount of attention in
in the in recent in recent years, because these
linear operator theoretic techniques are also
well suited for data driven implementation,
it turns out that data driven approximation,
where we use we use observations of
the system collected along dynamical
trajectories to build approximations of
the Koopman or transfer operator and use
them for different different purposes. The primary
applications being spectral decomposition of data,
it turns out that these operators when
you know formulated in an appropriately
on appropriately chosen spaces, they have
useful spectral property. So, the their
functions the Eigen functions characterize, can
characterize periodic or approximately periodic
observables under under the flow
and this can be used for the pattern
extraction or feature extraction from
dynamically generated data. And the other
application is prediction or modeling and
uncertainty quantification. Now, for
for the purposes of this talk here,
what we'll be focusing rather on the connections
between this approach this general framework of
Koopman Goodman and transfer operators with
quantum theory. So, mathematically, it turns
out there are some deep deep correspondences and
relationships between between the two fields,
which I hope I will I will highlight and and also
kind of like motivate this this framework as a as
a way to build a bridge to effectively
and called Classical dynamics in terms
of quantum quantum systems. So, this is like
a natural language in some sense to do that.
Okay. So, this may be here, maybe for this
audience, this is not strictly necessary,
but I have like a one slide summary of the
basic axioms of quantum quantum mechanics,
which we'll be using later on. And in
many ways you can think of a quantum
quantum
set of quantum mechanical
actions as being analogous to
classical statistics where you replace objects
like probability densities, which are functions
and observables, which are again functions by
operators. It's some type of, you can think of
it operator theoretical noncommutative version
of classical, classical probability. And the
one of the fundamental notions that we have
is that the density operators are basically a
quantum state, we're going to describe it by
an operator that acts on on a Hilbert space.
And that choice of killers, Hilbert space will
depend on the system at hand, for something like
the hydrogen atom, it would be like a space
of functions over a three dimensional space.
For a spin system could be like a finite
dimensional Hilbert space, this will depend on
the system that we have at hand. But but a density
operator is an operator that has that is positive,
meaning it's self adjoint. And its spectrum
lies in the positive real line. It's,
it has a it does have TRACE
Class, so it has finite trace,
and it's normalized in the sense that it's
traced is equal to one, you can think of it as
somehow being analogous to a probability density
function that one has in classical statistics,
in the sense that the probability
density function is a positive function.
It is integrable. And it's integral
is equal to one. So thinking here of
trace has been somewhat analogous to
integration makes that correspondence.
Now observables in quantum
mechanics are again operators,
in fact, they're self adjoint operators
acting on the Hilbert space. Here,
for simplicity, I'm going to think
in terms of bounded observables,
that doesn't necessarily have to be the case.
But we don't have to worry about that. Now.
And,
and the self join us here, you can think
of it as being analogous to having real
valued functions, classical observables. So
self adjoint operators have real spectra,
which is analogous to having real
being real valued functions. Now,
the quantum theory gives us a
recipe or look for a set of rules for computing
expectations of measurements of observables, given
that the system is in a certain quantum state, and
evaluating their probability outcomes, and again,
this generalized familiar notions from classical
statistics. So if we have a system that is in
quantum state roll, it has an associated density
operator row, and we have a bounded classical
bounded quantum observable, we can compute this
trace. And that gives us a number which is we
interpret as the expected value of measurements
of a when the system is in quantum state zero.
And again, thinking of a trace as being our
biggest integration role as being analogous
to probability density, and a as being
analogous to classical you know, observable,
the this formula here should look somewhat
familiar from somewhat analogous to expectation
of classical in classical statistics. Now, quantum
theory also gives us a recipe for computing the
probability of outcomes of measurements. So
if I have a we have a set omega that that
is like some set of interests, let's say
an interval, and we want to compute the
probability that a measurement of a
will rely on that integral interval,
we can compute that again, by as a quantum
expectation of a new quantum observable,
which is basically the spectral measure
associated with a, I don't want to go
now in the in more details here, but think of
this as being somewhat analogous to when you
want to compute the probability of an event
in classical statistics, you can write the
probability of an event as an expectation value
of a characteristic function that you know,
basically indexes represents that event.
Here the spectral measure is some quantum
version of a characteristic function. It's a it's
a projection operator, that we can use to compute
probabilities of measurement. Now, the evolution
of a quantum state takes place under unitary
dynamics between when when we are not measuring
the system so we assume that
there is a unitary operator
you
De that acts on densities maps pro quantum density
operators, the quantum density operators by means
of this conjugation identity. In quantum physics,
this is known as the Schrodinger picture of
quantum quantum evolution. And it's linear. That's
the meaning these operators here are linear.
And, and the last piece that I want to bring up
here is that just as in classical statistics,
we can condition probability densities.
By
when we have observed events, we using Bayes
rule, there is an analogous conditioning.
Procedure for conditioning quantum states by so
called Quantum events. So what are quantum events,
so quantum events are again, operators, everything
is an operator here, which have the property of
being positive and lying between the zero
operator and the identity operator, these
are also known as quantum effects. And, again,
you can think of this in my sort of classical
analogy with the fact that when you have an event
that you're conditioning, a probability density,
that event you can represent by a characteristic
function. And a characteristic function is a
function that takes values between the
zero function and the function that is
equal to one
everywhere and this, this generalizes that.
Now this formula here, you will see that you have
the square root that appears on both sides of the
density operator, which looks somewhat different
from the classical version of Bayes Bayes rule,
when you write it down. Well, the reason is
that we're dealing with this non commutative
spaces of operators. If we were able to
compute multiplication of the square root
of eight with row, we could write this as rho
times E, which would then look closer to what
a conditioning in the classical world would
look like. But because we're not in general
allowed to do this, this is the formula
that we are, we're going to be using. Okay,
so we have now this set of axioms, maybe pause
quickly to ask if there are any questions.
So what do
I do have a question? I'm sorry? So like,
can you? I'm a little unfamiliar, like coming
from a physics background? I'm familiar with,
like, point 124. Can you say
a little more about the fifth
point state conditioning by measurement?
Like, what is it? What are you measuring?
It's a so.
So
here, I'm thinking of,
for,
for every measurement, there is a chord
with one kind of sign by measurement here,
I mean, that these quantum events are effects.
So if you want to think of it's
purely as a without, you know,
focusing so much on the choice of words
here, and then I can try to clarify that.
Think of that whenever you have an
operator E that has this property,
it has this, it's called a quantum a quantum
effect, then then there is this, this, this
formula that is basically giving you a quantum
version of of Bayes rule. Now, when when you're
actually making a measurement, and if we want to
think at least of the measurement, as
a as I type of fire, have a yes or no
answer, yes or no question. It
turns out that you can write down a,
an effect you can write down and E for
depending on a depends on the weather,
you got the answer, yes, or the answer? No.
And you can condition the state by this,
by this effect. This is basically analogous
to what one might call the wave function,
quotes collapse. I don't know if I want to
really use that. That word, but this is basically
somewhat analogous. analogous to that, I mean,
for us, we're going to think of it more in in a
statistical sense, or, or we're going to use it in
a mathematical way, a sense
to update quantum states by
outcomes of, of observations of our system.
Hopefully this will become a little bit clearer.
error later on, but certainly can you say like,
this is what happens after you make a measurement?
In? Yes, you can, you can say about Yeah.
But but also and also, but
also you can use that formula,
not just in the context of a physical quantum
measurement, like in terms of like a hardware
based measurement, but you can also
think of it as an inference formula,
similarly to how you would treat,
you know, Bayesian Bayes rule for
inference. So, why don't terms his
kind of projection, yeah, subsidies?
Is this this map here? Yeah, it
projections will have property,
there will be quantum effects, but not
every quantum effect isn't necessarily
a projection. But yeah, that's a good point,
like projections are going to be part of this.
Okay.
Alright, so now, I want to go over like,
like a big picture picture overview of how we
use these these axioms to represent a classical
dynamical system by a quantum quantum system.
So as we mentioned earlier, we're starting
from from a classical dynamical flow on a state
space. And we want to embed this classical flow,
eventually to a quantum system. And we're
going to do this by passing through a few
intermediate levels. The first one of which will
be to embed a classical evolution of classical
states into evolution of classical probability
distributions, the way to do that here, so here,
P of X denotes a space of probability measures
over x. So with, you know, reasonable assumptions,
this, this is like a nice space in a
mathematical mathematical sense. And the,
the map that allows us to do that is basically
it's, it's very naturally takes points in X,
and maps them to their corresponding Dirac
delta measures at that point. So essentially,
what we're doing here, we're creating a copy of
our system into into this space of probability
measures that we can always do. I mean, there
are more, of course, probability measures in
here that just the direct measures, but we get an
injective mapping, like a one to one mapping into,
into the space p of x. And on this base p of x,
you can use this pattern for being an operator
that I introduced earlier on, which
is this. It's a composition map by
the inverse flog, it turns out
to evolve probability measures over time.
And the important thing about this type of
embedding is that it's dynamically consistent
in the sense that this diagram here commutes,
by that I mean that if you start from
a given classical initial condition,
you embed it into a probability measure,
sending it its corresponding Dirac
evolving it under the transfer operator,
you get to the same point as first
evolving your classical condition
and then embedding it with the same formula. So
it's dynamical consistent in that manner. Now,
what we want to do next is
starting from this, this, this
level of description, so to speak, we
want to now create another embedding,
which takes classical probability measures
into quantum states. So here h is a Hilbert
space that we will have to choose we'll
have to think about how to define it.
And Q of H denotes the space of quantum
states on that Hilbert space. So for us,
this will be the set of no TRACE Class
positive operators have units of unit trades.
And we want to define a mapping
that will be an embedding, that
we're going to hear gamma that takes probability
classical probability measures and creates you
know from them quantum quantum states. And we
also want to prescribe an evolution map that
acts on this on this quantum states. This will
be some kind of like lifted version of the parent
for Binion's operator that makes this diagram
commute. So in effect, this will give us this
will give us a copy of our system into an quantum
mechanical, quantum mechanical system. Now this
Islam is going to be typically
infinite dimensional.
In order to have, of course, practical algorithms,
we want to project into finite dimensions. And,
and in particular, we want to, if the goal is
to create quantum computational algorithms,
they want to project our system into a quantum
system that is defined on a Hilbert space,
which is associated with a certain number of
qubits. So it has b sub n here I'm denoting as
a tensor product, Hilbert space associated with
N, N qubits. The goal is we want to define a
project choose our projection map in a
suitable way, such that we can have a
evolution acting at the level of
qubits. That is, in some sense,
on the one hand efficient, that allows,
which means that we can implement it
with, you know, modest number of compute
lot quantum logic gates. And also, it's consistent
in the sense that this diagram here should commute
or at least commute asymptotically as the number
of qubits increases. And that is, that is kind
of the end goal. Now, the key points that I
want No, probably will not get to the very
end of everything that they wanted to say. But
so let me say, what are the key points here?
There are two points that I want
to highlight. The first is that,
even if we implement these methods
classically, like after all, you know,
these are basically one could, in principle,
simulate the system, classically, at the level
of operators is basically dealing with linear
algebra when you're working in finite dimensions.
What I'd like to do too, one of the
messages I'd like to get across is that
given if implemented classically working
with this quantum formalism to Castleton,
desirable or useful numerical, numerical
properties, and certain aspects of
structure preservation that are very natural,
almost automatic, and when you're working with
operators are like matrices in finite
dimensions, as opposed to functions,
I will focus here on positivity, preservation.
And the other the other aspect is that for some
classes of systems, I mean, which is by no means
an exhaustive class, I will specify that later on,
we do have a way to design circuits that
implement this evolution in a manner in a
manner that is efficient, or it has some type of
advantage. And I will, I will try to be specific
about what what is that advantage later on.
But these are the main, the main two points.
So I'm going to highlight give like
some examples from our work first,
we're dealing more with this, this
part where we design algorithms, which are quantum
inspired, but they're implemented classically.
And,
and then on the second part, talk about talk about
implementations on quantum circuits. So this is
this first part isn't work in collaboration
with David Freeman, and Brian meads, who are
PhD students from Dartmouth join us Lewinsky,
who is also from dark with an ARBUS almost from
University of Wisconsin, Milwaukee, and I
will be talking about ideas from from using
quantum information science or quantum theory
to perform data, data simulations of classical
dynamical systems. So what is the goal here?
In Data Data simulation? Well, the goal is that
you have the objective rather, is that we have a
dynamical system that we observe only partially
in a classical dynamical system,
and we have classical observations,
and we want to infer the state of that system
under sequential measurements. So the idea is
that we could start from highly uncertain
knowledge of the state. And even though
we're observing the system partially, over
time, we can refine our knowledge and get
a good estimate of the underlying state.
So this is an integral piece of many sort
of like numerical modeling systems like
weather prediction or object tracking,
and it has many applications in practice. So
so the the approach that we're going to use is
So, basically, along the lines of
what I've been describing already,
what I'm going to be here a little bit more
specific and how we actually define our Hilbert
spaces and our spaces of classical observables,
which I hadn't talked about previously. First,
you know, if we're going to embed into a quantum
sim, we have to choose a Hilbert space. So in the
context of data simulation, a natural choice of
a Hilbert space is if you have a dynamical system
that is measure preserving. So this is going to
be an assumption, we're going to assume that there
is a invariant probability distribution of the
system. Think of it that there is some kind of
statistical equilibrium, the system itself, like,
the probabilities, that we're going to be looking
at that do not have to be in, in equilibrium,
but we're thinking that there is some underlying
equilibrium distribution. And the probability
measures that we're looking at there, they
have densities with respect to that equilibrium
distribution. So this is the typical setup one
has in, in, in classical Data Assimilation. And
now as our space of observables, we're going to
look at bounded functions with respect
to that to that probability metric. Now,
we can think of this space, this the space
of observables, as it's actually an algebra
of observables. What do I mean by that, it has
the property of not just being a vector space,
like a linear space where you have addition and
scalar multiplication, but it's also it has an
extra operation, namely, you can multiply together
to two functions in the space. And they stay in,
in that space. And the operation is continuous
in a suitable sense, with respect to the norm of
the space. So we have an an algebra, and it is a
commutative algebra, because it doesn't matter in
which order you multiply, you know functions.
Later on, we're going to embed this in a non
commutative algebra of operators. So in fact, this
is what we're going to do now. This is how how,
how we embed our our classical probability
densities into into quantum state. So it's
the it's basically a formula that takes a
probability measure that has a density with
respect to with respect to the environment,
measure mu and call that density, I'm calling
it new. This is a function which is integrable,
because it's a probability density is positive,
so it can take its square root, and
it's quieter, there's going to be
square integrable. So it will live in our
Hilbert space. And if we define that, that
operator, which is a projection operator
that projects along the square root of the
probability density that defines for us a quantum
a quantum state, this is a density
operator. So this procedure is known as the
Koopman. Von Neumann, embedding, Ilan and others
have done a lot of work on this on this topic,
or even more general versions of this where you
allow also the density here to cover complex,
a complex phase. This is this
here, we're looking at real valued
densities.
And so we have this embedding. And
the nice thing about it is that it
makes this diagram commute where the
commutation here the evolution of
quantum state takes by means of the of the
Koopman operator acting on on probability
on density operators by this conjugation
formula we had talked about earlier. Now.
So we've we've talked about how to embed
a classical state. Now, we can also embed
classical observables. After all, we want to have
both representation of states and observables as
a quantum system. And the way we can do that
is basically by mapping functions to bounded
operators on our Hilbert space. So this will be
quantum observables, which are multiplication
operators that multiply by those functions. So
here pi is a map takes a function to an operator,
so pi of F is an operator. And pi of f is defined
as the operator that multiplies by F. So in
quantum mechanics that are in quantum physics,
you know, multiplication operators, there are
many examples of them one, one of them being let's
say, the position operator in a one dimensional
one dimensional system. Here
we're defining them for general
observables in the space L infinity. It is
important that we looking at bounded above
deliverables because to make this operator
bounded this multiplication operator and
the consistency relation that we
get at the end. So this is why this
diagram commute. And this is why effectively
we're creating a copy of our system in into a
quantum system is that we can compute,
we can use the transfer operator to
evolve classical probability densities, and
compute expectations. Classical expectations,
without a time evolve with respect to the time of
all density, or we can embed quantum mechanically
use the quantum mechanical version of the transfer
operator and computer quantum expectation of the
corresponding multiplication operator pi of
f. So basically, it's this formula over here,
and we get the same result as the classical
expectation. In other words, we have created a
copy for all intents and purposes of our system
into this infinite dimensional quantum quantum
system. Now, we want this, of course, at the end
of the day, we want to do numerical computation.
So the next step will be actually to, as I
mentioned earlier, as well, will be to project
the system onto finite dimensions. Now, here, I'm
not focusing on doing quantum computing. So it's
not important that the, the Hilbert space, the
finite dimensional Hilbert space is has the tensor
product structure associated with with qubits,
here, we're imagining a more general situation,
we'll have some finite dimensional Hilbert
space, which is a subspace of h of our infinite
dimensional Hilbert space. And we orthogonal II
project everything onto that onto that subspace.
Now we can we can project states assuming
that this denominator here, doesn't,
doesn't vanish. So for every state for
which this denominator doesn't vanish,
we can project down a state from the
infinite dimensional setting to a finite
dimensional state. And we can also create
an evolution of of states by means of this.
This formula here, which we're basically using a
projected projected quantum is projected Koopman
operator for for that for that part. Now, in
general, if we do that, this diagram here does
not commute. That's why I put here this dotted
arrows unless you know in some special cases,
for instance, if if HTML was a finite union
of Koopman eigen spaces, then you know,
for particular choices of H sub L, this
diagram will commute exactly, but we don't
want to restrict ourselves in that situation.
However, if we have L as being some parameter
that controls the dimension of our approximation,
and as l increases, these spaces increased ours H
these diagram here will commute in asymptotic
asymptotic sense. So this, this is the level
that we operate numerically, we have basically,
our quantum states our density matrices, now,
there are finite rank, finite rank operators and
numerical linear algebra with matrix algebra.
And this is now one of these highlights that
I was I wanted to make earlier is that this,
this numerical setup allows us to easily
preserve some structures of the problem that
would in ways that would not be possible by
if we were working in spaces of functions.
And what do I mean by that? Well,
if you take a classical probability density like
a function, which is a function which is positive,
if you do an orthogonal projection of a positive
function, let's say you were representing in a
numerical scheme, a classical density as a in
a basis like in a Fourier basis or some type of
discretization basis that one chooses, if you're
using an orthogonal projection to arrive at your
approximation, that approximation need not
be positive. And you know, there are things
behaviors like the Gibbs phenomenon, for instance,
when you take a top cut function and you project
it into finitely, many Fourrier functions
which do not do not preserve positivity,
at least not through orthogonal projections,
you have to do something more or less trivial
in order to preserve positivity. On
the other hand, preserving positivity
of operators is is much, comparatively much
easier. If you take an operator and you call
aggregated from the left and right by a positive
operator when you conjugate it by projections,
the result is, is a positive operator.
So the the, the the message here is that
by by passing first by embedding first our
system into this infinite dimensional quantum
system and using that as our starting point to
build numerical approximations puts us in a,
in a space where we have the ability to
preserve certain aspects of the original
system like positivity of states, but also
it turns out positivity of observables in
ways that are either not possible in spaces
of functions using equivalent operations like
orthogonal analogous operations, like
orthogonal projections. So, I would,
I would advocate that this is a reason to at
least think about these type of methodologies,
even if the if they're not implemented in quantum
computers, even if they're used in classical
Numerix. Okay, so, in the in data simulation,
as I mentioned earlier, we imagine that we have
a classical system that is evolving over time,
we are, we don't have knowledge of its state,
but we observe it state every, you know, certain
number of times that if we're doing some kind of
this discrete in time
approximation.
And we're going to represent our knowledge
of our of that system by by a quantum
state. So in data simulation, classical
data simulation, this knowledge would
be represented by a probability density.
Here, we're going to use a density matrix,
like, like we had before. And the
idea is that we alternate between
forecasts and measurement. This is the
typical cycle one has in data assimilation,
between observations, we use the transfer
operator acting on density matrices to evolve
to evolve our density to a new density.
And then when the when we measure make a
measurement of the system, and by measurement
here, I mean, purely in the classical sense,
we have a sensor like a or like a network
of sensors that are giving us observations,
we're measuring a function of the state of our
classical system, there is we use the quantum
version of of Bayes rule that I showed earlier,
to update the state. And for that, we have to use
basically a map like I was talking about earlier,
we have to assign to every observation and a
corresponding quantum effect. So like a quantum
event, if you want to think of it like that way,
we do that in practice using kernel methods,
like feature maps, from reproducing kernel
Hilbert spaces, with a difference that being in
the quantum in the quantum world, we have to use
a matrix valid or operator valid feature maps, I'm
happy to talk about some of this offline later on.
So and, you know, in the scheme,
we it's basically numerically we
can implement it using data that we
collect along dynamical trajectories
in a training phase. So it's basically
like a data driven data simulation scheme.
So I guess I talked through that. So in
the interest of time, I will not spend
too much time here. But just to just I want
to emphasize that we can compute predictions
or forecasts of classical observables
using quantum expectations, but we can
also put it in place we're basically carrying
representing entire forecast distributions,
because we, with our quantum state, and
the spectral resolution of our observables,
we can compute probabilities for measurements
to take values in different sets of interest,
let's say you want to predict the temperature
at a given location, you know, two days from
today will will lie in a certain interval,
this can be encoded in this in this manner.
Okay, I'm going to show one example, where we did
that in the context of climate, climate dynamics.
So this is using data that is training that was
generated from a climate model. So currently,
we're working also on on doing this from
actual observational data, but the idea
Is that we're making observations of the impact
of Indo Pacific sea surface temperature fields.
So we're observing the temperature of the surface
temperature of the ocean, in in a domain that is
roughly like shown here. And from that we
want to make a prediction about the El Nino
phenomenon. So the linear Southern Oscillation is
an oscillatory process that manifests itself with
anomalous anomalously warm or anomalously
cold waters in the tropical Pacific Ocean,
to the west of South South America.
So linear events are anomalously warm,
and the corresponding landlines are anomalously
cold, this is an oscillation that takes place
with a characteristic timescale of three to seven
years, approximately, currently, we are in an El
Nino here. And the way climate scientists
index or monitor this, this phenomenon is
by means of conventional at least by means of so
called Nino indices, so that these are basically
area average sea surface temperature fields over
given domains in the tropical Pacific Ocean,
we're going to use this Nino 3.4 index, which
is the average SST in this box over here,
which is probably the most one of the more
common indices for, for answer. So we took this
data, and we, you know, we
ran it through the pipeline,
but I just mentioned, and this is basically just
an output of what this method produces. So these
are basically running forecasts of the El Nino,
Nino 3.4 index in a think 50 years, or
sorry, 20 years of an arbitrary interval
of a test data set that we have isolated from,
from this model. And in the in the red line,
we're showing the true evolution of the meaning
of 3.4 index, the black line is showing the
evolution that the quantum that we get from the
quantum expectation from this from this numerical
numerical scheme. Here in the horizontal axis, we
have the forecast verification time. So it's like
the day for which we are making the forecast. And
as we go down the panel, where we are increasing
the lead time is how many days in advance, we are
predicting and the behavior here that and that you
can see. Well, I should also say that the colors
here correspond to the probability or logarithms
of the probability density that, again, is encoded
in our quantum state computer through the spectral
measure of our observable that we're using to
also characterize uncertainty of forecasting.
And you can see as we go down the parallels, as
one might expect, forecast uncertainty increases,
as well as you know, the error for the
forecast, but it's doing a pretty decent job,
at least for these type of model, modeled data.
Okay, so I think I'm almost
running out of time. So I will
skip, you know, basically a lot
of what I had in mind, I will say,
maybe just a few words about the actual quantum
quantum implementation if I
can take three two. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. So so. So in this part, and I'm just
going to give a quick summary of this. We
are now interested in in besides, you know, this
numerical, you know, classical numerical procedure
that I, you know, outlined, for data simulation,
that we're interested in actually implementing
this, you know, the versions of these algorithms
onto quantum quantum computers. So, this is work
done with people listed listed here. And, and
the, the focus here is that rather than having
our finite dimensional approximation, space be
a general in a finite dimensional Hilbert space,
we want to explicitly focus in the case where
the Hilbert space that we're projecting has the
structure of an n fold tensor product of two
dimensional Hilbert spaces associated with an
N qubits of a quantum computer. So this base
here will have dimension two to the power n.
And there is a there is basically a canonical
basis that one can choose for for one can use for
For this tensor product Hilbert space that
you can represent by binary strings indexed
by binary strings of length, length n, and
the basis vectors are tensor products of
these basic vectors that are, we label them
this Dirac ket notation equals zero, and one.
So we have this, this setup here. And, you
know, this space here has dimension two to
the power n. So, an exponential large dimension
we want to create here, the goal is to create
an evolution project, create find a projection
map such that maps are transferred operator into
a finite dimensional finite rank operator
that can be implemented efficiently using
ideally, using a polynomial
number of quantum gates
in this exponentially large dimensional
Hilbert space. So, this is something that
we're actively working on so far, you know,
and we've had a lot of discussions with Elon
and others on that as well. So, so far, we
have looked at this particular case of SOC
on systems that have purepoint spectrum. So these
are canonically, we can represent them as ergodic,
rotations on on Toray. So this formula that
I'm showing here for the dynamical evolution,
this will be our canonical working example. But
in fact, this this is representative of a wider
class of systems. So we can bring other systems
that have this beautiful and spectrum property
into this canonical form, have an ergodic towards
rotation by continuous continuous transformations
that are compatible with a dynamic these
are known as topological conjugates. So
this will be our canonical example that
we're going to, we're going to study
I'm going to skip here through a
few things. But the idea is that we
want to choose a Hilbert space that is
adapted to this, to this kind of this,
this type of systems. And, and we're not going
to be using Enel to space in this application,
we're going to use a different
class of Hilbert space known as
a reproducing kernel, Hilbert space, which is
defined by means of a kernel that we have on our
on our torus. And the key property that this space
has, in addition to being a reproducing kernel,
Hilbert space, that it's also again, a, an
algebra with respect to point wise multiplication
of functions. This is a non trivial property to
have for reproducing kernel, Hilbert space. But
for this specific choice of kernel that we're
using, we have it. And the reason is that we
want to have these properties because we want to
represent classical observables of functions in
that Hilbert space by bounded multiplication,
multiplication operators, and these type of
these class of spaces have been studied
extensively in harmonic analysis. In
fact, thinker and collaborators
and among you know, there's a large
literature and we've made some
contributions in that as well.
I'm going to, you know, skip a bunch of stuff. The
The point being that with this particular choice
of spaces, we're going reproducing kernel, Hilbert
algebras, were able to return retain a lot of
structures that is, you can find in in different
spaces, but here, we're putting them all in one
place setup. And this is useful for, for designing
our quantum algorithms. Okay, so the main point
is that, you know, once we go through this
machinery, is that if we take a system that
has purepoint spectrum, and we look at it, we can
find basically a projection map that takes our
Koopman operator or more precisely, the generator
of the Koopman group to a Hamiltonian. So we're
defining we're using a Hamiltonian to define a
quantum system that is very nicely vectorizable
in in terms of as a sum of computing operators,
which are very simple in the sense that each
operator each of these operators that appears in
the sum is a tensor product of identity operators
with only one policy operator that acts on
an individual qubits. So effectively what
we're doing we're representing this ergodic
system that has purepoint spectrum has a a
bunch of phaser rotations that are
acting on individual qubits. This is very
special. Because it won't work for any dynamical
system, I want to stress that it's actually non
trivial to generalize it. But But for these
kinds of systems, we do have an efficient
representation of our quantum coming on, but
allows us to exponentiated and get a very nice,
very simple, almost trivially
simple quantum circuit.
This is how the pipeline work. As I mentioned
earlier, you know, in addition to the the
evolution, which we do efficiently by our
secret that I've just highlighted are the
highlighted there are these problems of how do
you encode the initial condition? And how do you
make a measurement at the end, where gives you
which gives you a consistent information about
the observable that you want to predict,
there are ways to address it. And I'm not
talking about this today, namely, the state
preparation can be done efficiently using
Hadamard gates. And at the end of the of
the Koopman. Evolution, it turns out by
applying a quantum Fourier transform, which
is also an efficient in the sense of being
because a quadratic cost is required circuits of
quadratic depth in the number of qubits. After
doing this quantum Fourier transform, it turns
out that measurement in the quantum computer can
be decoded into a measurement of the classical
observable that one is interested in predicting.
And this scheme has this positivity preservation
property that we talked about earlier,
it is asymptotically consistent as the number
of qubits increases, and it has an advantage
in this very specific sense, I don't want to, you
know, over definitely not want to over claim here,
in the sense that it can simulate spaces of
observable which are exponentially large,
using circuits that have quadratic depth.
So the running time of the algorithm is
quadratic in the number of qubits.
And that allows you to simulate the
evolution of observables in an exponentially
large dimensional Hilbert space. So I'm just
showing here one or two examples, where
we have applied that into into simple
you know,
systems like harmonic oscillators,
or quasi periodic systems that live
on a torus. So to have a more
interesting, this is evolution,
this is comparing the the true evolution
with the ensemble mean that one obtains from
a collection of quantum
measurements done at the end,
or sorry, from an ensemble of quantum
identical, we prefer quantum systems
that this is done in a simulated
quantum circuit experiment. So you
can see that with certain number
of qubits we can get, we can get
a reasonable reconstruction
of the true evolution. And
that's gonna be the last point, we
also had some actual experiments
done on a IBM Quantum computer
using three qubits. So this is,
admittedly, for a very simple system,
just the harmonic harmonic oscillator.
We're beyond that, we found that basically,
the noise in the quantum computer
prevented us from getting
any meaningful, any meaningful result. But I
think this is encouraging because at least we
get a consistent, you know, this is like an
ideal quantum circuit versus the actual one
bit for this system, simple
system, we can get a consistent
reasonably consistent correspondent. Okay,
so with that, I will stop and I'll just
leave this here and I am sorry for taking
a little bit longer. Okay. Well, thank
you so much. There is a wonderful talk.
And let's have a q&a session. Although
we had a question in the middle during
the talk, is there anyone who wants to ask
questions, please unmute yourself and ask
and for those of you who are in person in
that room, and physically, please, please
ask questions as well if you have got one. Well, I
can start with one when you when you in your show
the chart like showing the classical the dynamics
and there is a mapping from classical to quantum
and quantum to competition quantum computation
all that there is a mat you have to define right.
And is that mat has to be linear
Alright.
So with respect to the input space, no,
actually it's Yeah, I mean, that's one
of the few places where the mappings
are not linear. Like, if we look at,
sorry, just go back real quick.
If you look at this map here, this this Koopman
von Neumann embedding, this is actually a
nonlinear map, because it involves, basically, you
know, we're doing operations like square roots.
And so this is actually these mappings are
one of the few places where this scheme is,
is nonlinear, the other places the measurement
when we do the quantum state updates.
But yeah, in general, these mappings
here are are not not not linear.
Yeah, it's just fascinating to me. I mean,
me being not familiar with this the subject,
how, how people identify those nonlinear map.
There must be some, some rules.
Oh, well, I
don't know if I can say something
too intelligent. Maybe Elon will
have some comments on that. But
like, if I were to get a cover
shot is like,
there are maybe some,
at least some guidelines like you want.
Like, for instance, you might say, Okay,
we want to have our classical probability
density, if we're going to look for a so called
vector state vector state, it means that it's a
density operator that you can characterize by a
specific wave function. So it's like a single
function that characterizes like our rank one
projection operator. So we have to basically
identify like a function that is a unit vector,
since this is a projection operator
from the data that we were given,
namely, valid probability density. And,
well, since a probability density is a
positive function that integrates
the one, if I want to turn it into
a unit vector on a Hilbert space, which
is contained square integrable functions,
well, maybe the square root
is not a bad, no, a bad idea.
And here's the formula.
There's a more principled way of thinking
about this. Yeah, yeah. I mean, but I mean,
there's also non linearity in
the sense of the choice of like,
how you pay like, what coordinates a you
choose on space. So like, right, like how,
you know, like, because H and x are very
different objects and gamma like gives you
an enormous amount of freedom and how you make
that justification, but like, you know, and
maybe you want if the dynamics
has been based on symmetries,
so, you want to like encode that with
a proper choice of coordinates on x,
then the symmetries need to have
a special representation on ah,
you know, having to do with how that gamma lab
is acting. But in general, I mean, in general,
I think, you know, construction of these maps
is kind of like a sort of cutting edge research.
Dimension is, you know, colleagues
have done amazing work, you know,
in terms of pushing the envelope here, got it
got it? Well, from, from the perspective of,
you know, videos to the hotel guy, and I'm one of
them, and this operator mapping that we do all the
times in the context of you know, we generally
the reason we are doing that operator mapping,
because the oldest know the dynamics is in really
really high dimensional space and you want to
reduce that to low dimensional space and that
mapping like typically we call it compression,
there are linear map and nonlinear map and
we do that all the time to bring those high
dimensional space to the low dimensional space.
And as you guys mentioned, you know, if there is
some physical property we would like to preserve
it follow that rule, those physical property
to guide us to come up with those mapping
like from high dimensional to low dimensional
Yeah, so there is a some connection
between vom and I mean, one
definitely, you know, a clear example
with DMT DMT is the
one Kumon operator. And it does the Delete
linear compression, like the SVT type of mapping
high dimensional to low dimensional. One thing I
should note is that this is this eclipse this map,
this is kind of like the opposite of a
compression is like an extreme sort of
the level of inflation. Yeah, it's because
it's a lift, because you start from a space,
which is in something much smaller than, than
the space, we're creating a copy of probability
measures into quantum states. Yeah, I mean, what
compression happens when we go from here, and then
we go to these like level of density matrices.
And that you can, that is a compression, like,
there's a, there's a concept called the
lift and something and where there's a,
you know, the original governing equation is very
complex, nonlinear. But you do the augmentations,
basically lifting what you just said,
and in order to transform that complex
nonlinear problems to the quadratic problems,
and then once you convert that to quadratic,
it's easy to deal, you know, the reduced father
to low dimensional space. So there's a walk by
that German people, and also
Karen Wilcox in UT Austin.
Are you familiar with that? Yeah.
Lift and learn? Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, it's, it's in kind of a similar?
Yeah, I think that's a common strategy
like that you going to bigger spaces, gives
you maybe more flexibility than to, to design,
you know, approximation schemes that have some
properties that you couldn't easily get otherwise.
And you guys, that's what you're doing. Right?
And basically, at least in this in this example,
yeah. Because here, there's nothing
specific to quantum computing, I mean,
this, you could just, you know,
think of it purely as a numerical
data driven scheme for data simulation, it
gives you this type of benefits. And again,
I'm not arguing that there are no other ways,
of course, there are different ways
of enforcing positivity, you know,
in in, you know, approximations.
But, but, you know, the thing that
was trying to argue is that certain
operations that are non trivial in
function world, like, for instance,
you know, how do you make sure that you
preserve positivity of positive functions,
they become somehow, almost automatic, I would
say, in the operator world, because it's easy
to preserve positivity in this, in this case,
it's easy to preserve positivity of operators,
under projections.
Interesting, interesting. But there are other
similar, I mean, I didn't talk about this at
all today, but like, for instance, if you, if
you're interested in representing generators,
which are first order differential operators
of deterministic dynamics like that,
the one of the fundamental like, algebraic
properties is that they satisfy Leibniz rule,
like, if I take the derivative
of the product of two functions,
we know how to do that, you know, with a put
there is a product rule for differentiation.
And there is no non trivial
operator that satisfies that
rule on finite dimensional
spaces, commutative spaces, so if I take a
function space, and I discretize, it somehow
I cannot satisfy the liveness rule.
But on the other hand, it's very easy to satisfy
the Leibniz rule with matrices. If you take,
for instance, if I have a matrix A, and I
think the commutator between that matrix
and any product of other matrices, have a
look at the commutator of A and B times C,
then it follows that, you know, the
satisfies basically a liposomal. So it's
a you know, there are certain operations
that certain structures that are easier to,
to represent in finite dimensional using
spaces of operators than functions.
Cool, cool. Very interesting. Well,
is there any other questions? Maybe. Can
I make just a couple of times? I mean,
I think that there's two
Maybe difference or two interesting
differences between what's happening
here and any other sort of dilation
technique, which is that, you know,
in addition to like coming up
with this interesting mapping,
you're also working with the quantum
probability theory. And you've like,
augmented your understanding of
what the rules of probability do.
There's potentially value in that. And, you
know, so the second comment is, specifically,
if you were modeling the evolution of an
actual quantum system, you would need to use
those types of probability rules like the, what
you spoke about as like the quantum Bayes rule,
that's, that's essential for actually doing
data driven modeling of quantum systems.
And
there's, like an enormous effort, you know,
in trying to do that, across the country,
you know, almost every university, but I
mean, right now, we have Stephanie Clifford,
sitting in the room right? There. She's
working on ideas like that for modeling,
you know, actual quantum hardware that people
are building at the lab. And so it's you're
augmenting your ability to do these data driven
systems, you're not just in the representation of
in your notion of probability, which means
the difference being you can form what are
called the superposition states, where you
can be in a combination of zero and one.
Like, Demetrius didn't talk much about
what, how qubits differ from classical bits,
but you know, they can have a probability
anywhere between zero and one. In fact,
they're, like, represented
a two dimensional manifold,
that's the surface of the sphere. So like,
you would never be able to work with that
object naturally, if you've applied, you
know, the standard rules of probability
that almost all of these frameworks are
built on any kind of Bayesian analysis.
And here, you're actually augmenting your ability
to deal with these quantum systems naturally.
So there's some physical systems for which this
will most certainly be a much
more natural representation.
I mean, that shouldn't be like it reported,
but I know it's very abstract. But But like,
they're, like, almost all fundamental
systems have a quantum mechanics. And so
that means there should be some evolution
in the way we think about probability.
Yeah.
I think that's a very good point. And
maybe related to that. We haven't
started this at all, but like,
what might be interesting to think
about is that once you go to this,
you know, finite dimensional, again,
representation, but then you're using
quantum versions of probability
and up, you know, Bayesian update.
Is there anything to be said about having more
capacity to encode information or make more? Yeah,
a better representation of your
underlying, you know, unknown,
classical state with for the same number
of for the same dimension? Basically,
you know, just basically, just
because you're accessing all these,
you're accessing potentially more
states, that quantum, you know,
in your statistical representation of the unknown,
you know, hidden state of your dynamical
system, but maybe there are some benefits. So,
I don't know, like, Well, I mean, you showed
one at the very end, like, where are you,
you know, basically, you could interpret
the theorem that he talked about the end of
saying there was an exponentially efficient
representation for any integrable dynamical
system. And what you're able to do then
is to dynamically evolve an exponentially
large number of states, essentially,
for the cost of, you know, you know,
a single or you know, logarithmically
smaller amount of information. Because
you basically code this in the set of qubits.
So, it's, I mean, it's, you don't
get something for nothing, but,
but you do get an A certain type of quantum
advantage that is potentially very valuable.
I mean, doing this for for chaotic
dynamics, which is more generic, it's not
is easy.
But like, you know,
again, that sort of cutting edge like
how would you how would you do that?
Anyway, I hope. So it's like some
of these operations are actually
if you had a quantum computer, you
can do them much more efficient.
If that makes them
like exponentially more efficient,
depending on what kinds of
questions we're trying to ask
it step by step there
am Oh, good. Well, I mean, I mean, I don't know.
I'm guessing you're very inspired by Dimitris
talk, maybe you can combine, you know, the
neural new neural ODEE idea you're
applying, maybe you can apply that
after some mapping, and then to the
neuro operator, and your neuro od TV.
That's sort of the combination.
What do you think Stephanie?
At this point is a little over my head.
This is really the first time I see a
talk like this. I think I'll just so maybe
me maybe additional meeting with
Stephanie would help. Sounds good. Oh,
all right. Well, I'm in there was one.
For example, in the first one is Ukraine
for scaling for its n square in the bottom
implementation. That's it, but you have extra
time evolution? Doesn't this square includes time.
So good point. So this circuit,
it's for one, the moment, at least the
way we have set it up, it's for one,
this is giving you the evolution
at the end of this for one fixed,
fixed time. So that one time step four,
it can kind of be as, as long as you
want it to be integrable. So you can fast
forward it. So you can, okay, so sub linear
scaling. Exactly. Is that because, you know,
yeah, usually, this is an interesting question,
like, what's the complex complexity of
the evolution operation here? And it's a
very interesting question, from the point
of view of quantum algorithms, you know,
can you attain linear scaling and the
time steps are, some algorithms have
to do automatic number of time steps like
quadratic work with number of time steps,
which is weird compared to, you know, classical
systems. But here, because it's integrable,
you can essentially, you know, fast forward the
videotape all the way to the final timestamp,
and immediately print the result, at least fast
forwarding is specific for quantum specific for
integrable systems for you. Let's cover
this purepoint spectrum problems. Yeah,
actually a distance where it includes
measurements. So if you perform free estimations.
Yeah. And the reason that we do that is, because
one of the issues with quantum computing is
that you're not you can't measure any quantum
observable at the end, you have to measure, you're
stuck with measuring a specific one associated
with a quantum computational basis. So the
qubits, so you want to rotate the state such that,
in that, in that, when you do make
that measurement, it actually gives you
a correspondence with the underlying
classical thing that you're trying
to predict. And it turns out the quantum
Fourier transform for, for the, for the
class of these multiplication operators that
we use to represent our classical observables,
approximately diagonalize them.
So that means that you can,
by doing the quantum Fourier transform,
you rotate your state in a way that
a quantum measurement can be encoded,
or decoded rather into an eigenvalue
or a measurement of the multiplication
operator that we care about. You kind
of measure index in a spectrum and
after vertical Yeah. Yeah. And the
last question is about this forecast,
Data Assimilation or measurement cycle.
Maybe you can go to the slide
Yeah.
So basically, understand you need to
perform this forecast and until now
This is for some G, some J, some, yeah, J is the
number of sorry, I was going too fast here the
number of time steps between observations. After
if you perform equal back to analyze another time
step, you will need to repeat everything
from. Okay, so that's, that's another good
points are here. This is you can think of it as an
inference procedure. Similarly to, like Bayesian,
like sequential Bayesian inference in classical
statistics here, we're not doing any physical
quantum quantum magic. Yeah, that's a great
point that, you know, one of the challenges,
I think, with implementing an algorithm like this,
which is sequential in nature, is like, and you
are actually doing real quantum measurements,
that because those will destroy your state.
Afterwards, it just was, I was curious,
maybe you kind of do your measurements,
you collapse the state after that you
collapse state, regional state, but
now you just collapse, measure and repeat.
Yeah, we will. Right now we're
not doing any physical, physical
measurement. So in other words, we don't
have to explicitly like, pre pre prepare,
you know, the standard, we can simply apply
this rule to obtain a new density operator.
Okay,
I think extending it to the full time
case would be really interesting.
Yeah, and maybe there are something
to be said here. There could be some
role for quantum sensors, like in the sense of
Yeah, like
to be able to couple the, the quantum
state with the whatever we get from,
from the underlying system, whatever
we obsess on the underlying system,
without destroying it. I don't know if that's
I mean, yeah, it depends on
on the level of description.
You could certainly destroy it, or you don't
necessarily destroy it, you just project it, yeah.
But, but, but then maybe the other issue
is like, when we do actually want to make
a forecast like meaning to get a number
out of it right, then then we do have to
destroy it in some sense,
like project it along and
establish
action state
done attend,
if you object to something, you
cannot continue in your time.
I mean, it will have a
different different evolutions
may have even the same Hamiltonian
just a different starting from
you know.
I mean, yeah, I think people I would love to
see people working this out,
but I can be it's pretty bad
for dealing with the final information directly.
I mean, I mean, but
at the same moment, before measurement, you
have some positional states that together
describe time evolution, but if you
collapse it, you will have just one
time step and basically
use quantum problems with a
vital response. Well, I mean, maybe you
just project it in Ancilla. Now here
you.
Okay, I think that that's the final comment
from the peanut gallery over here. It's
not was not monitoring the
chat or anything like they
couldn't see the hotdogs? No. There
is no question from the chat. Yeah.
Unless there's other questions from the audience.
You can jump in.
I see Lee here. And also,
Ben here.
You guys are welcome to jump in. Otherwise,
from the perspective of you know,
formal GDPR seminar, maybe we can just
end it and stop the record button and
just continue the discussions. Well, let's in that
Spirit let's thank our speaker
two materials have a wonderful
talk and nice nice q&a sessions
thank you so much you're probably